episode 3 of Obi-Wan is here and I'm
here to talk about it why because of the
film properties out there Star Wars is
one of the last ones that people don't
take too seriously anymore
also for my money this was the best of
the three episodes I mean if you're
asking my opinion which is my channel I
feel like that's what you're here for
okay and spoiler alert I'm gonna talk
about spoilers you need that spoiler
alert for this one I'm just saying all
right so in this episode of Obi-Wan
Kenobi I know you want me to just go
ahead and talk about it we need to build
up we need to build up to it no I did
like this episode
mostly I feel like Austin Powers and
gold member where he's like that said I
do have some thoughts I feel like
lucasfilm should have a department a
division of people known as the nitpick
division a department of people that
come through outlines and scripts for
Star Wars movies and shows looking for
all the contradictions and lore all the
nitpicks that YouTube douchebags like
myself are gonna point out like Grand
Inquisitor being dead
it's not even a nitpick that's a big
like what the [ __ ] anyhow Obi-Wan's out
there trying to get Leia to safety and
then he runs into Stormtroopers they run
into Stormtrooper which when it started
getting heated I was like why not just
be like
you were never here I did like with
Obi-Wan and Leia when Obi-Wan's talking
about Leia's mother
and
he's talking about Padme that was cool
that was really heartfelt but there's
this Commander who's actually good which
I like that they addressed it because
you know as you get older and lore
expands and well not Laura it's your
perception of rebellions and Empires and
how these things unfold you think like
what about the commanders who aren't bad
they just realize that they are now
fighting for the bad guys like when
Padme was like you ever think we may be
on the wrong side but I do reference
that
can't think of the name but it was it
was the name of a person a Jedi and I
was like he's from Clone Wars hello
comment section thank you for filling
the comment section with the answer to
that cool reference also I was like I
was more living Jedi out there because
the Empire's not very good at their job
remember Yoda was like the last of the
Jedi you would be no it's like that was
like 10 more out there it's just fine
all right so Grand Inquisitor is dead we
got a couple of answers on this episode
couple of insinuations anyway we're
closer to the answers one grand
Inquisitor seems to be dead it seems
like he's just not out there or is part
of Vader's master plan like he's alive
but they can't know it it's all part of
my scheme better Rebels Grand
inquisitors a different Grand Inquisitor
than Obi-Wan Grand Inquisitor who
happens to be the same species but
Vader's like look my quest to find Tic
Tac head-shaped Grand Inquisitor
commences round head Grand Inquisitor
you can go ahead and be dead they're two
different people I don't know it's weird
that someone who died in Rebels is dead
now before Rebels and Riva and Vader
have had FaceTime and apparently he's
totally cool with the fact that she
knows that he's Anakin Skywalker or was
and I know I said people don't live
through knowing that and people are like
dude Grandma of Tarkin and Grandad roll
thronner I meant people who
Grandma tarkin's one of the two people
that Vader actually took orders from in
the original Star Wars so I get that he
can know and it's fine Grand Admiral
thrawn's Master tactician blabbing that
information to the Galaxy would put the
Galaxy in more civil unrest the pr would
be a nightmare so I get that the emperor
knows that he's not gonna blab but I'm
just saying someone undervader in the
order of inquisitors which you see in
here you see in this episode there is
Intrigue among the inquisitors and the
storyline there it's plotting they're
scheming there's people like hey I want
to be the new grinding quizzer I'm next
in line it shouldn't be you but as that
is in Adobe one series it feels like
they're making two different shows two
different shows that have gone Splat
into one show which logistically is kind
of dumb it's like all right you have the
Riva Inquisitor storyline and the
Obi-Wan Kenobi storyline you fuse them
into one show that's half the views you
would get because I'd clock in for an
Inquisitor show I'm just saying why
wouldn't she make it a separate show you
could double your views and double the
profits I I don't get it because there's
Intrigue with the character Riva it's
like is she evil does she have some good
she obviously has her own angles she's
playing I actually wouldn't be surprised
if some years down the road we find out
that a Star Wars Inquisitor show was
planned to be its own thing and they're
like I will just fuse it into Obi-Wan
and make it an obi-one job bummer is I'm
not here for that right now I'm here for
the Obi-Wan story Obi-Wan meeting Vader
and well here we are it happened in this
episode Vader strolls into this town
that was actually really cool man it was
like seeing the monster it's like oh my
God the monster's here and he's walking
through this town I mean Obi-Wan is
feeling a myriad of emotions I imagine
he was just like that's it oh my God
he's terrible he's like force choking
people and breaking their necks in front
of Obi-Wan trying to I think anyway this
is the way I interpreted it trying to
get an emotional response out of Obi-Wan
so we can sense where Obi-Wan is he can
sense the fear and the pain and they had
their face to face I was like okay they
had their face to face and a lightsaber
duel a lightsaber fight of sorts it's
kind of a shoddy one but it happened in
episode three like this in terms of
climbing and in tension and build up I
would think you would have that in
episode six of a six part series but now
they meet the dialogue is pretty much
like what have you become I am what
you've made me and that's that they have
a couple of slashes a couple of fights
it's not that like I'm like dude when
fan films do it better because I don't
even care Star Wars sc38 reimagined
that's Canon as far as I'm concerned so
I feel like the confrontation they
should have held off on that I imagine
there's going to be another one where
this was the one where it kind of
shocked everyone caught him off guard
and they have like Clash Clash all right
it's over and there might be another one
I'm just saying they probably should
have held off on the confrontation until
the last episode also this whole thing I
felt like was a retcon or at least an
explanation for what Vader told Luke in
Return of the Jedi where he said Obi-Wan
once thought as you did when Luke was
like hey come with me father and so but
Obi-Wan never thought that Obi would at
least never said that Owen was like I
will do what I must kill you so I was
like okay so that's gonna be in this
show but that wasn't really the dialogue
so there has to be another confrontation
another face to face at least but the
more you have Darth Vader and Obi-Wan
square off or Clash before A New Hope
the less special that confrontation
between Obi-Wan and Darth Vader and A
New Hope becomes you're diluting the
currency so to speak my favorite part of
it is another thing where I'm like so
does that insinuate does that imply that
Obi-Wan has half his body burned right
now bath to tanks to heal everything but
is when Vader takes this flammable
liquid across the ground and lights it
and then just pulls Obi-Wan into the
fire that was actually really cool and
poetic you know Obi-Wan was thinking at
that moment he was like this is a
fraction of the pain Anakin went through
when he had his whole body burned
there's a difference between knowing it
and knowing it it's the difference
between knowing and feeling you know now
Obi-Wan has felt it but I remember
seeing a story where fire
freaked Vader out like he's afraid of
fire so either that's Legends or just
not taken into account the Obi-Wan
series or maybe he got over that fear
because he's like no fear is my strength
fear and pain right I Gaze on the fire
and I remember how much it hurts and it
hurts him that way
it would have been kind of neat if you
just see Vader take a step back while
he's burning Obi-Wan you know just one
shot of his foot or something just to
insinuate that he just doesn't want to
be that close to fire just one line fire
at least it's not sad in the end I like
this episode of Obi-Wan Kenobi more than
the other two episodes yeah I wish
they'd held off on the Darth Vader and
Obi-Wan having their face to face thing
and I will say if Darth Vader hadn't
pulled Obi-Wan into the fire I would
like it less there was just there's
something about that that I like maybe
I'm a dark person but you know Vader was
thinking like this is what it felt like
[ __ ] Obi-Wan was like oh this is
what it felt like [ __ ] I just I
like the fact that he felt his pain for
a second the thing that really hit me in
here was when Riva was going to the
inquisitor's stronghold and is playing
this other theme that's just not the
Imperial March it's like who owns the
rights to The Imperial March can we not
play it in Star Wars anymore because it
would go a long way to making it feel
like the same universe the same word
world if the Imperial March played when
Imperial types were on screen doing
their thing in Imperial palaces and
Imperial places I mean in a world where
Mark Wahlberg's ringtone and Ted played
The Imperial March apparently what they
can play it in Ted they can't play it in
Star Wars movies in Star Wars shows I
just find it weird it's like why would
you not have that kind of continuity in
the universe all right so episode 3 of
Obi-Wan Kenobi did you love it did you
hate it what'd you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]